alright Pixar's back now let's see if
they'll make up for cars to brave now
brave is the story of Princess Merida
she doesn't want to be ladylike she's
this really cool chick she wants to
sword fight and do archery like Legolas
or Robin Hood or link some of the
archers out there but the customs like
no you got to get married act ladylike
which is like no I don't want to get
married I want to change my fate I want
to do what I want to do but the setup of
this movie is really cool you end up
liking her you're like she's a complete
badass you like her weird little family
Billy Connolly is her dad's the best is
Billy Connolly is the old dude from
Boondock Saints how was he not ever the
best they got this cool backstory to the
four kingdoms and she's like I'm gonna
go change my face so she goes to change
her face and you think okay this is
gonna be cool there are so many ways to
change your faith that have to do with
magic which this movie does it just
blows your mind and most of them are
pretty cool and then she does it she
changes her fate and then you're just
like I've just smacked headfirst into a
kid's movie and that's the best I can
describe it the movie changes its entire
vibe so fast that it goes from a disney
pixar type movie which is really cool
setup you're liking the characters
you're a full grown adult going I like
these characters this is cool I can see
where this is going they're making up
for cars too you know adults alike this
kids'll like this everyone's gonna be
happy then you like it she just did the
thing to change your fate and it's a
kids movie now which is such a waste to
the whole changing your fate thing she
could have had a thing where she changed
her fate and the kingdoms fall apart
because of it so now she has to deal
with that someone could have died and I
think that's the thing I think someone
should have died but this is a kids
movie so I can't have someone die which
is crap because I know that Disney
movies are not above killing people
there's a whole action and consequence
thing that can happen in something like
this but not really I mean there's
consequences but it's kid movie
consequences and after that the movie
goes from being badass to me I'm being
cute I think that's another thing this
movie doesn't really have a villain you
can argue the movie does have a villain
but no it does not have a villain I'm
actually the villains the metaphor of
her own cells stop stop there is no
villain a movie about a badass chick who
wants to change her fate who's good at
archery and then in the end the biggest
bad guy in the movies a bear yeah you
heard that right how unexcited is that
sound the bummer is it is a Pixar movie
Pixar has set the bar so high for
themselves that people expect movies
that are good for kids and adults and
when you have
half the movie leading up to look like
it's gonna be like that only to be like
no it's still for kids I said what a
bait-and-switch in the end I like the
main chick she was cool I like half the
movie I like the build up but then when
I get sucker-punched with a
bait-and-switch of a kids movie that
changes the entire vibe way too quickly
I can't say I like the entire movie and
it just kind of killed it for me I will
say it's a good time no alcohol required
subtext if you're a kid if you're an
adult it's okay but you're not gonna
remember it in t-minus a couple days yep
already forgot she goes and gets this
magic she doesn't like the result so she
goes to get a refund that's the movie so
your favorite heroine ever say a word
and you're like that doesn't sound right
heroines drugs your favorite hero chick
that's not a word that's actually drugs
who is she comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more